[Musica]
questo è un ponte siamo nel 1952 a mosca
al centro di ricerca kurchatov un gruppo
di ricercatori sta testando una
tecnologia con lo scopo di ottenere
energia virtualmente illimitata pulita
senza scorie o sottoprodotti rilevanti
siamo in un'epoca in cui la guerra
fredda in escalation piuttosto rapida e
il progetto infatti è classificato come
top secret
anche questo è un ponte ma di questo ne
parliamo tra poco ora torniamo agli anni
50 i fisici russi poco dopo anche quelli
europei ed americani erano convinti che
sarebbe servito poco tempo e risorse
relativamente limitate per ottenere una
tecnologia così profondamente
rivoluzionaria
entrambi i blocchi sovietico e
occidentale erano infatti reduci da una
prolifica serie di studi sulla bomba h
la bomba a idrogeno ovvero una bomba
termonucleare il principio con cui
funziona la bomba a idrogeno è in
qualche modo simile a quello che avviene
all'interno del sole due piccoli atomi
elettricamente cariche collidono fondono
i loro nuclei e sprigionano una
gigantesca quantità di energia quello
che gli scienziati in questione stanno
cercando di ottenere è lo stesso
principio ma in un ambiente controllato
lo scopo quindi ora non è più generare
un arma super potente bensì produrre
energia tramite la fusione nucleare o
nuclear fusion
del resto però costruire una stella
sulla terra è piuttosto complicato e
denari solo presto difficoltà dal punto
di vista ingegneristico delle scienze
dei materiali della fisica teorica e
della fisica dei plasmi un momento
chiave che rappresenta una svolta nella
storia dello studio della fusione
avviene nel 1958 a ginevra alla
conferenza soprannominata poi atoms for
peace atomi per la pace
uno degli obiettivi di questa conferenza
era quello di riunire
i gruppi di ricerca più rilevanti al
mondo e di presentare lo stato dell'arte
dello studio sulla fusione rompendo
quindi la classificazione top secret
questa già un ponte meraviglioso si
giusta di una quasi unanime conclusione
per cui il sistema migliore per
controllare questa stella questo sole e
attraverso un reattore dalla forma
toroidale un cosiddetto tokamak in due
parole è una ciambella metallica
circondata da bobine che generano campi
magnetici sufficientemente forti ed
accurati tali da poter controllare
questa stella questo sole confinarlo e
stabilizzarlo per un sufficiente periodo
di tempo ma quanto ci spaventano i
cambiamenti benissimo se potessimo
ottenere energia dalla fusione oggi non
cambierebbe assolutamente nulla nella
nostra vita di tutti i giorni
semplicemente eviteremo di distruggere
il pianeta come sta avvenendo adesso
adesso anche adesso atoms for peace è un
punto di svolta dopo il quale scienziati
di tutto il mondo cominciarono intense
collaborazioni ed in particolare intorno
alla fine degli anni ottanta europa
stati uniti russia e cina gettano le
basi per una collaborazione
internazionale con lo scopo di
dimostrare la fattibilità della fusione
sulla terra il progetto si chiama iter
international thermonuclear experimental
reactor ed è attualmente in fase di
costruzione a cadarache nel sud della
francia nella regione della provenza
iter che l'opera tecnologica più
complessa mai realizzata dall'uomo sarà
in grado di generare un plasma di 100
milioni di gradi
dieci volte più caldo del centro del
sole ea pochi metri da questa
relativamente piccola ma caldissima
stella dell'elio liquido utilizzato per
il raffreddamento di alcune componenti
avrà una temperatura di meno 270 gradi
quindi nel giro di pochi metri il punto
più caldo è uno dei punti più freddi
dell'intero sistema solare andranno a
coesistere in peter
nei decenni scorsi sono comunque stati
costruiti altri reattori sperimentali
per lo studio della fusione tra i più
rilevanti vanno citati già ad oxford asd
asd ex upgrade a monaco east in cina e
dietro i di a san diego alla general
atomics in california attualmente io mi
trovo in questa sede e o principalmente
due sensazioni che viaggiano in
parallelo dentro di me
la prima è sicuramente gratitudine per
poter far parte di un progetto così
profondamente proiettato nel futuro
la seconda è una sorta di responsabilità
considerato che questo può letteralmente
modificare le sorti del nostro pianeta
questo ovviamente vale per tutti i
ricercatori che come me condividono
questo viaggio fantastico ma facciamo un
passo indietro da mediocre talvolta
pessimo studente alle scuole superiori
come sono arrivato fino a qua
sicuramente un lavoro strepitoso e
faticoso da parte dei miei genitori ha
fatto la differenza
sicuramente ho avuto anche molta molta
fortuna nel trovare professori che mi
stimolassero nel modo giusto ma un
elemento chiave che mi porto dentro
ancora oggi è la cultura hip hop e pop è
un movimento culturale che nasce negli
stati uniti agli inizi degli anni
settanta e che comprende al suo interno
la musica rap i graffiti il dj è la
break dance è sostanzialmente poesia in
movimento un ponte unico il cui motto è
pace amore unione e divertimento
l'ho conosciuto con tutto ciò che non
era a scuola ma tensione con questo non
voglio assolutamente dire che lo studio
non apporti benefici anzi specialmente
ad oggi lo studia parte integrante della
mia quotidianità bensì che coltivando le
proprie passioni che si viene portati in
luoghi dove uno non avrebbe mai pensato
di ritrovarsi un modo per andare oltre i
propri limiti che siano questi imposti
da noi stessi o dagli altri è il sogno
l'obiettivo che ti permette di diventare
quello che non pensavi poter essere mai
ma quindi come ha influito un movimento
apparentemente così distante nella mia
vita e nel mio percorso di lavoro e di
studio
sicuramente mi ha insegnato il silenzio
e la
molto così come dai ragazzini passavamo
interi pomeriggi cercando di assimilare
ogni singola parola che ci veniva detta
dei ragazzi più grandi
così oggi parte del mio lavoro è
studiare ed ascoltare opinioni di
scienziati più anziani che hanno fatto
la storia nel nostro campo sicuramente
mi ha insegnato anche la pazienza perché
così come prima di poter partecipare ad
eventi importanti si passano anni di
cosiddetta gavetta
così oggi mi trovo coinvolto in un
progetto che vedrà la luce dopo il 2080
esattamente probabilmente non potrà
nemmeno assisterci di persona mi ha
insegnato anche il rispetto verso chi ne
sa di più di me certo ma anche verso chi
ne sa di meno di me perché tutti siamo
stati principianti almeno una volta in
tutto sono l'attitudine il metodo che
questa cultura mi ha trasmesso che mi ha
permesso di focalizzarmi in un qualcosa
di molto più grande di me in un'ottica
collettiva e non individualista
tutto questo può essere racchiuso in un
vecchio detto afroamericano che ritengo
oggi essere più attuale che mai
each one teach one
anche questo è un po holder grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]